In the final verse In the final verse
of chapter number 73, of chapter number
73,
verse number 20, verse number 20,
has mentioned in this verse which we
which we discussed
discussed has mentioned in this verse
a a kind of a bird's eye view of kind of
a bird's eye view of
last night. last night.
And that is the discussion of whether
whether this verse
this verse And that is the discussion of
was revealed was revealed in the Meccan
era in the Meccan era
or the Medinan era. or the Medinan era.
And the correct opinion, And the correct
opinion, and and both both opinions
opinions have their scholars and their
have their scholars and their
those who have adopted it. those who
have adopted it. However, the However,
the correct opinion is that it is
correct opinion is that it is Meccan or
Medinan. Meccan or Medinan.
Meccan or Medinan? Meccan or Medinan?
Medinan. Medinan.
What's the conclusion we came to last
last night?
night? What's the conclusion we came to
That it is That it is
that it is a Meccan that it is a Meccan
verse. verse.
Even though it seems Even though it
seems out of place out of place in the
sense of in the sense of
the the rhyme scheme rhyme scheme and
the verse lengths and the verse lengths
of the verses that preceded it in the
preceded it in the same chapter, Surah
same chapter, Surah of the verses that
al-Muzzammil, al-Muzzammil, and it has
mention of things that and it has
mention of things that were only really
were only really
obligated obligated in Medina, in
Medina, jihad jihad and and
zakat, zakat, etc. etc.
However, we'll get into However, we'll
get into the reasoning behind that.
that. However, it is a Meccan chapter.
However, it is a the reasoning behind
Meccan chapter.
Allah Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
ta'ala says in this chap- in this verse,
this chap- in this verse, subhanahu wa
verse number 20, verse number 20,
[Silence]
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to, "Indeed, your Lord,"
speaking to the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, "Indeed, your Lord
knows
that you stand for prayer in the night
a little less than
2/3
or even half
or
1/3 of the night each night
along with a group of those who are with
you amongst your companions."
And it is Allah who
has
designated who it is Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has is the one who has judged the
lengths of the
night and day, and he is the one that
alternates
the lengths
lengths of the night and day.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala,
He knows that you will not be able to
sustainably
stand for prayer in the entirety of the
night every single night.
Fataaba alaykum.
Hence, he has
relieved you.
And
that relief is recite of the Quran what
you are able to.
It changes every night. Some nights
you'll be able to pray half the night,
some nights 2/3 of the night, some
nights 1/3 of the night, some nights a
portion, some nights a lot or a little.
And this goes with
the human being and the human being's
abilities. We're not robots.
You cannot predict a person's spirit
tomorrow.
The scholars tell us
wal laha adbar.
Fa
an-naaji
wan-naajih
wal-muflih
huwal-ladhi idhaa aqbalat
nafsuhu istaghalla iqbaalahaa.
Wa in adbarat mana'ahaa
[Arabic recitation]
The scholars tell us that a person's
spirit,
his nafs,
it has days when it is very anxious
where when it is very
enthusiastic,
and it has other days where it is much
less enthusiastic.
We have days where we are ready to get
out of bed and face the world, and we
have days where we can barely roll
ourselves out of bed.
So, what is the
true
hallmark of a person who is in control
of his nafs?
It is someone whom when his nafs, when
his spirit,
when his enthusiasm, it is is at its
peak, he capitalizes on that enthusiasm.
And he does and squeezes as much as he
can out of that enthusiasm.
But on the days and nights when that
enthusiasm is at its minimum,
and a person finds that his nafs is
fighting him,
that he places a boundary of bare
minimum that he expects from his nafs.
So, what does that mean? Meaning,
let's say a person wishes
to recite one juz of the Quran, one part
of the Quran
every night in salah and qiyam.
There's going to be nights
where he is tired, where he's in pain,
where he's sick, where he's unable, he's
traveling, he is under
certain kind of stress, what have you.
In this instance,
the person places a bare minimum.
Say the bare minimum is one page.
But on the days when I'm really feeling
it, I'll go up to one part, two parts,
three parts, as much as I can.
But I place a bare minimum, a line in
the sand. And I
tell my nafs, "This line in the sand
will never be crossed.
I will never
miss my five daily prayers.
I will never miss my sunnah salah,
and I will always at least make two
rak' at night and one rak' for
witr."
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
taught us this,
this methodology.
He says sallallahu alayhi wa sallam,
Yaa ahlal-qur'an,
alaykum bil-witr. Inna Allaha witrun
[Arabic recitation]
"People of the Quran,
stand for witr.
Allah is witr, he is one, and he loves
that
odd number on that odd cap, that witr on
your prayer."
And the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam has been narrated to have said,
[Arabic recitation]
yaqulu,
man lam yusallil-witra
falaysa minna.
Whoever does not at least pray the witr
salah, he is not one of us."
Now, what does this mean? Some scholars
have viewed this to mean that witr is
obligatory. However, that is the
lesser or the less correct opinion.
The correct opinion is that the five
daily prayers are what are obligatory
upon a person,
except that which is obligated because
of an occasion or an event or an
occurrence.
Okay, that's outside. But a constant,
continuous
every single day is the five daily
prayers.
A man came to ask the Prophet sallallahu
[Arabic recitation]
and he said, "You have to pray five
daily prayers in your day and night."
He said, "Is there anything more
obligated upon me as far as prayer is
concerned?" He said, "No, unless you
wish to
unless you wish to
offer that which is more.
When the man left, he said,
He said, "I swear by Allah I will not
add to what you have commanded me here,
nor will I take away." The Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said,
He will be successful if he is true in
what he has said. The scholars take from
this that recurring
daily prayer, there is nothing
obligatory outside of the five daily
prayers.
However,
this doesn't mean that a person that
foregoes something as simple as one
raka' for witr
has not
fallen short in
a bare minimum of that which is
optional. And that is what the scholars
have understood these narrations to
mean.
In Sahih al-Bukhari,
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said,
regarding a man
who sleeps all night
and misses prayer,
He says Sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
"That is a man whom a shaytan has
urinated into his ears."
into his ear. Why the ear?
Why the ear?
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says,
The ear is the only thing that stays
awake of your
senses while you sleep.
And so how were the people of the cave
made to sleep for
all those decades?
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
covered their ears.
He put them completely to sleep
senseless and separated them from their
bodies in that way.
When a person sleeps through the
entirety of the night and misses salat
al-fajr or misses salat al-isha, a
shaytan has urinated in his ear.
Not only is it a humiliation from a
shaytan, but it is a way that a shaytan
uses to prevent a person from connecting
with Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala during that
critical time.
In Sahih al-Bukhari, the Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam tells us that
when a person goes to sleep,
a shaytan comes
and ties three knots
onto his head.
And then he pats those knots and says,
He You know, when you finish doing
something, you kind of
tap it. It's finished. Put the final
touch on it, right?
A shaytan, he ties these knots on a
man's head
before as he goes to sleep at night.
And then he pats his handywork and says,
"Sleep.
Enjoy the night's sleep."
Your enemy is watching you while you
sleep.
He's watching with a smile. And why is
it three knots? The scholars tell us
that if he wakes up
and the first thing he does when he
wakes up is remember Allah, one of the
three knots becomes undone.
And if he gets up and makes wudu, the
second of the three knots becomes
undone.
And if he stands to pray at least two
raka' or more, all three knots have
become undone.
So when you wake up
and you pray, even though this is no
longer obligatory. This was at the
beginning of Islam.
Now it's not obligatory anymore to pray
at night. Now we have the five daily
prayers. These verses were before the
five daily prayers.
Now we have the five daily prayers.
But to get that extra edge on your
enemy, a shaytan,
you wake up, you first first thing you
do when you wake up, you remember Allah.
This is one of the highest levels
of remembrance in all of the Sunnah.
Is that as soon as your eyes open, your
tongue
moves with the remembrance of Allah.
The second thing you do
is you fight off that warmth.
You fight off your your wife's soft arms
around you. You fight off that soft
pillow.
And you go and you make wudu.
The second knot is undone.
And then the third thing is you stand
and you make
at least two raka'. Let's say a person
said,
"We want to start making salat at night.
How do we at night? How do we do it?"
You start with what Allah says, "Faqra'u
This statement, "Faqra'u"
it's a reference to recitation, but it
really means prayer.
And we will discuss the intricacies of
that
on Wednesday night, insha'Allah. But the
point is is that pray what is easy for
you.
If you start out hot and heavy,
you're not going to be able to sustain
that. Start with a number
and then stick to that number.
When your nafs is enthusiastic,
give it more to carry that day.
But when your nafs
is down,
don't let it cross that line. I'll end
with this one thing.
There is a
a statement that Ibn al-Jawzi made in
his book Sayd al-Khatir, a very
interesting statement.
He said,
"A man in dealing with his nafs has to
be a king deals with his subjects."
You have the image here?
A A man in dealing with his nafs to get
it to to get it to do what he needs of
it,
he needs to use siyasa.
He needs to use the same diplomacy
that a king uses with his subjects.
How was that?
He says, "If the king is too strict
and too tough
and too tyrannical, they'll overthrow
him.
They'll overthrow him and put him to
death and they'll dance around the
guillotine.
But if he is too lenient
and he's constantly joking and letting
his subjects do whatever they want,
they'll never take him seriously and he
will be relinquished
to be nothing but
a a a cardboard cutout, a silhouette of
a king."
There has to be a middle ground that he
takes with his subjects.
He shows mercy when he's able to
when he's able to
when he's justified, he shows mercy,
but he does not allow his subjects to
overstep their bounds.
And this is what Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
tells us here in this verse.
So this verse is teaching us the
beginning
fundamentals of how to deal with our
nafs and how to combat the aggression of
our enemy, a shaytan.